En los últimos meses, la palabra BREXIT se
ha convertido en un sinónimo de APOCALIPSIS
para casi todos los medios de comunicación.
Al menos, los de fuera de Reino Unido.
Mientras tanto, en VisualPolitik os hemos
mostrado la cara más positiva y, a la vez,
menos conocida, del BREXIT.
Ahora bien ¡Eso no significa que todo sean
ventajas!
“Goldman Sachs trasladará cientos de trabajadores
fuera de Londres por culpa del Brexit”
Y este es sólo un ejemplo más.
En el momento en el que hacemos este vídeo,
20 bancos han anunciado ya que moverán buena
parte de sus plantillas fuera de la Reino
Unido.
Las estimaciones más optimistas dicen que
la City de Londres perderá unos 30.000 trabajadores.
Y las más pesimistas aseguran que esa cifra
podría llegar a los 200.000.
Y sí ¡Ya sé lo que estáis pensando!
Hace unos meses os asegurábamos en este mismo
canal que la City de Londres sobrevivirá
al Brexit ¿Significa esto que estábamos
equivocados?
¡La respuesta es no!
Hablamos de la capital financiera del mundo
entero, no sólo de Europa.
Londres puede mantener su influencia en los
mercados financieros de Asia o incluso EEUU.
Pero las finanzas europeas suponen el 35%
del trabajo de la City.
Y, por eso, el hecho de no estar en la Unión
Europea, tiene sus consecuencias.
Y ahora os preguntaréis ¿A dónde van a
ir todos estos bancos?
¿Cuál será la nueva capital financiera
europea?
Tras varios meses de competición, con campañas
publicitarias incluídas, parece que ya tenemos
un ganador.
“Los bancos y las empresas planean expandirse
a Frankfurt tras el Brexit”
Efectivamente.
Todo apunta a que Frankfurt se va a convertir
en el nuevo financiero de Europa.
Y tal vez, uno de los más importantes del
mundo.
Pero ¿Qué tiene Frankfurt que no tengan
otras ciudades como París o Madrid?
Hoy vamos a responder a esta pregunta pero
antes… vamos a ver un poco de historia.
¿POR QUÉ LOS BANCOS DEJAN LA CITY?
Os lo hemos contado en varias ocasiones, Londres
es la capital financiera del mundo.
Más concretamente, la llamada City de Londres,
que es como una ciudad dentro de una ciudad.
La City, es un área de poco más de un kilómetro
cuadrado que tiene sus propias leyes, su propio
alcalde y hasta su propia policía.
En este espacio es donde tienen sede los principales
bancos del mundo y donde trabajan más de
300.000 personas.
De esas 300.000 personas, 60.000 son inmigrantes
europeos que entraron en el país gracias
a estar en la Unión Europea.
Y sí, es cierto que Reino Unido nunca estuvo,
oficialmente, en el espacio de libre circulación.
Es decir, que teóricamente, el Gobierno Británico
podría haber cerrado sus puertas a todos
estos inmigrantes.
Pero, en la práctica, los ciudadanos europeos
podían entrar y salir en el país como Pedro
por su casa.
“Claramente, la inmigración europea a Reino
Unido se ha incrementado significativamente
en las últimas décadas”
Sin embargo, parece que las cosas van a cambiar.
La primera ministra británica, Theresa May,
está en una posición política extremadamente
débil.
Aunque haya ganado las elecciones de junio,
ha perdido buena parte de los diputados que
tenía anteriormente.
De hecho, ni siquiera está claro que vaya
a mantener su cargo de Primera Ministra por
mucho tiempo.
Y está recibiendo presiones, tanto desde
dentro de su partido como fuera, para endurecer
los controles fronterizos.
“Siempre he dicho que el voto del referendum,
era un voto para que cambiáramos esa libertad
de movimiento y pusiéramos controles a esa
inmigración que viene de la Unión Europea”.
La City de Londres sería una de las zonas
más afectadas de todo el país.
Buena parte de su éxito se debe a que son
capaces de atraer a los mejores profesionales
de todo el mundo.
Pero si el Gobierno británico les cierra
sus puertas, estos bancos que contratan inmigrantes
lo tendrán mucho más complicado ¡Y ojo!
Que no sólo estamos hablando del Brexit.
En realidad, la presión anti inmigrantes
en Reino Unido va mucho más allá de las
fronteras de la Unión Europea.
“Theresa May pondrá un impuesto a las empresas
de 2000 libras por cada trabajador que contraten
de fuera de la Unión Europea”.
¡Pero esperad un momento porque hay algo
más!
Como os decía, los conservadores de Theresa
May han perdido buena parte de los escaños
que tenían en la cámara ¿Y qué otro partido
ha salido beneficiado?
¡Efectivamente!
El partido laborista, cuyo lider, Jeremy Corbin,
es un enemigo declarado de los bancos.
En su programa, ya proponía cosas como esta.
“Los laboristas piden un impuestos a las
transacciones financieras en Reino Unido”
Hasta ahora, este impuesto era una de las
grandes bazas con las que contaba Reino Unido
frente a la Unión Europea.
Como ya sabéis, en Bruselas llevan años
debatiendo la posibilidad de cobrar una tasa
por las transacciones internacionales.
Este impuesto es como el hombre del saco en
el mundo de las finanzas.
Ningún banco quiere verse obligado a pagarlo.
Y el parlamento británico terminara aprobando
semejante tasa, muchos entidades se pensarían
si les sigue compensando seguir en Londres.
En otras palabras, que aunque las condiciones
que se negocien en el Brexit sean maravillosas
para Reino Unido, el ambiente que se respira
en este país es cada vez peor para su sector
financiero.
Y eso explica que tantos bancos estén empezando
a abrir sus oficinas fuera del país.
Pero…
¿Por qué eligen Frankfurt?
Ahora mismo lo vamos a ver…
LA CAPITAL FINANCIERA EUROPEA
El mismo día que se anunciaron los resultados
del referendum del Brexit, se dio el pistoletazo
de salida para competir por el puesto de capital
financiera europea.
Por ejemplo, la Comunidad de Madrid, sacó
su propia campaña publicitaria para atraer
a los banqueros.
Incluso el ministro de economía español,
Luis de Guindos, se reunió personalmente
con directivos de bancos como JP Morgan o
City para ofrecerles impuestos bajos.
En París, Emmanuel Macron, ha anunciado bajadas
fiscales para los bancos londinenses.
Sin embargo, ninguna de estas ciudades puede
competir con Frankfurt.
“Standard Chartered, Nomure Holdings y Daiwa
Securities group han elegido la ciudad alemana
como base para mantener su entrada en el Mercado
común.
Citygroup, Goldman Sachs y Morgan Stanley
están sopesando la misma decisión”
¿Pero qué tiene tan especial esta ciudad?
Pues bien, de entrada, Frankfurt es ya la
sede del Banco Central Europeo y de muchas
grandes entidades financieras como el Deutsche
Bank.
Eso significa que ya existe una red de empresas,
despachos de abogados, gestorías, etc…
Frankfurt además cuenta con varias escuelas
de negocios de fama internacional, una universidad
y el segundo aeropuerto más grande
de Europa.
Por si esto fuera poco, el 70% de la población
alemana habla inglés con fluidez.
Es decir, que los bancos británicos pueden
enviar a sus directivos a Frankfurt, tener
reuniones internacionales y contratar a población
local sin tener barreras de idioma.
Puede parecer una tontería pero en Francia,
sólo el 39% de la población es capaz de
entenderse en la lengua de Shakespeare y en
España, el porcentaje no llega al 25%.
¡Pero esperad un momento porque todavía
hay más!
Como os decía en otro vídeo, Alemania es
un país descentralizado, donde los gobiernos
regionales y los sindicatos tienen mucha más
autonomía que en otros países.
Gracias a esta estructura política, Frankfurt
puede prometer cosas como esta:
“Las leyes laborales alemanas hacen que
sea muy difícil despedir a gente.
Frankfurt ha propuesto un cambio en estas
leyes que eximiría a los banqueros o, en
general, a los que tienen sueldos altos, de
estas regulaciones”
Y ahora pensad una cosa ¿Qué es lo primero
que necesita un banco para poder establecer
sus oficinas centrales en una ciudad?
Un edificio ¿Verdad?
Lógicamente, necesitarán algún lugar donde
poder construir sus oficinas.
Pues en este aspecto, Frankfurt es la ciudad
perfecta.
Tras la II Guerra Mundial, Frankfurt quedó
reducida a cenizas.
Y la tuvieron que reconstruir, prácticamente
desde 0.
En otras ciudades alemanas, no se pueden construir
rascacielos para no romper con el paisaje
urbano, que es más tradicional.
Pero en Frankfurt, puedes levantar edificios
tan altos como quieras.
Eso explica que, que pese a que no tiene ni
un millón de habitantes, su skyline parece
el de una gran metrópolis ¡Pero la cosa
no se queda aquí!
Alemania es uno de los mercados inmobiliarios
más baratos de Europa.
Tal cual como lo oís.
Aunque los sueldos sean altos, las casas,
los alquileres y el metro cuadrado os sale
casi a mitad de precio que el de París.
Y no hablemos ya del de Londres…
¡Y esperad un momento!
Porque creo que desde aquí puedo escucharos
a alguno de vosotros diciéndome…
¡Fonseca!
¿Y qué me dices de los impuestos para las
empresas?
Efectivamente, en Alemania, el impuesto de
sociedades puede llegar hasta el 30%, mientras
que en Reino Unido no supera el 20% ¡Tenéis
toda la razón!
Pero, nuevamente, el diablo está en los detalles.
En Alemania, el impuesto corporativo tiene
dos segmentos distintos: uno nacional y otro
regional.
Es decir, que el Gobierno Federal solamente
cobra un 15%, el resto depende de cada región.
En otras palabras, que la región de HESSEN,
que es donde se encuentra FRANKFURT, tiene
margen legal para reducir el impuesto.
Y, desde luego, eso serviría para atraer
a muchos más bancos londinenses que todavía
no están muy convencidos.
Por otra parte, ese impuesto a las transacciones
financieras del que hablábamos antes…
parece que en Europa va a tener mucha letra
pequeña.
Uno de sus mayores defensores es, precisamente,
el ministro de finanzas alemán, Wolfgang
Shauble, y mirad lo que dice al respecto…
“Incluso un queso suizo tiene algo más
que agujeros.
Tiene que haber algo entre ellos.
Si no, es sólo un agujero, no un queso suizo”
–Wolfgant Schaeuble
Así que os dejo con esta pregunta.
Imaginad que sois los directivos de uno de
esos bancos londinenses ¿Qué haríais?
¿Os quedaríais en Londres o, tal vez, empezaríais
a mover vuestras oficinas a Frankfurt?
Podéis dejarme vuestra respuesta en los comentarios.
Mientras tanto, si saber más sobre los planes
que tiene la City para sobrevivir al Brexit,
haced click en este otro vídeo.
Como siempre, no olvidéis que sacamos vídeos
nuevos todas las semanas así que suscribíos
al canal para no perderos ninguna de nuestras
actualizaciones.
Si os ha gustado el vídeo, dadle a LIKE y
nos vemos en el próximo.
Un abrazo y hasta pronto!